I had a friend,
a songwriting mentor
and a great songwriter, John Stewart,
who told me just before he died,
"We are all just radios,
hoping to pick up each other's signals."
I found that to be true and profound.
And I've spent my life
trying to clear the static.
The strongest signals
that come to me are musical
in the form of songs or stories
told in rhythm and rhyme.
Sometimes I can tune in
to a revolution in the heart.
Sometimes I hear a keen
from my Celtic ancestors.
And some songs have been
postcards from my future.
In my family, there was a song
for every loss, every celebration,
every unspoken need, every longing.
But there was also so much chaos
that often I was the only one
who recognized
what was being communicated.
My grandmother, Carrie Cash,
moved with my grandfather
and their five children
into a New Deal era colony
created by FDR for poor families
in the sunken lands
of the Arkansas Delta in 1935.
So they moved into this freshly
painted cottage,
and she gave birth
to two more babies there
with the assistance only of a doctor
who came by in a horse and buggy
and pulled two loose aspirin
from his pocket to give to her.
The same pocket in which he kept
his fishing worms.
(Laughter)
That's true.
I read once that every time
an old woman dies,
a library disappears.
And before her library disappeared,
I tuned into my grandmother's signals
and gleaned her tenacity
which I borrowed,
and her long suffering in her life
of constant work with seven children,
six of whom made it to adulthood.
In a house without electricity.
In the sweltering cotton fields,
and I wrote these words about her.
(Music)
(Singing) Five cans of paint
in the empty fields
And the dust reveals
And the children cry
the work never ends
There’s not a single friend
Who will hold her hand
in the sunken lands?
And the mud and tears
melt the cotton balls
It’s a heavy toll
Oh, oh
His words are cruel
and they sting like fire
Like the devil’s choir
Oh, oh
Who will hold her hand
in the sunken lands?
(Music)
The river rises and she sails away
She could never stay
Oh, oh
Now her work is done
in the sunken lands
There’s five empty cans
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Applause)
In 1992,
I was writing a song about my divorce,
which hadn't happened yet.
(Laughter)
But which I saw coming
like a freight train.
(Laughter)
So I was stuck in this song
like I was stuck in my life.
And the same time across the country,
my mother was going through a box
of my school assignments
and childhood drawings,
and she sent it to me.
So I started going through this box,
and I came across this yellowed paper,
this school assignment I had done
in the seventh grade
in Catholic school
on metaphors and similes.
Now I vividly remember the pleasure
I took in that assignment
because it was literally the only thing
the nuns had ever given me
to do that I enjoyed.
(Laughter)
So this line I had written
popped out at me.
"A lonely road is a bodyguard."
What did it mean?
I had even pasted a picture
of this empty road
next to the line.
It was a metaphor.
It wasn't "a lonely road
is like a bodyguard," a simile.
It was the much more poetic:
“A lonely road is a bodyguard.”
As painful as that was then,
and as it still can be painful now,
I knew what she was telling me.
That ...
Solitude can protect
the seeds of creativity.
And that loneliness contains
a priceless gift
if we can tolerate the initial discomfort
and avoid the seduction of despair.
So my 12-year-old waved at me
across the decades,
saying that who I was
was who I would become.
And I waved back
and I dropped her line
right in the song I was writing.
(Singing) I’ll send the angels
to watch over you tonight
And you send them right back to me
A lonely road is a bodyguard
If we really want it to be
(Music ends)
We're all just radios
hoping to pick up each other's signals.
And some of those signals
have a backbeat and a melody,
and they're universal.
And music can unlock a frozen memory
that melts into the seeds
of our creativity.
And the reverse is also true.
A memory can unlock a song
that's waiting to be written.
It can reveal us to ourselves
across time and generations,
in community, in solitude.
Some frequencies are sound,
and some frequencies are light.
And some take a half a lifetime
to reach their destination.
(Music)
(Singing) Light is particle and wave
Our histories written large upon the page
The star in middle age
The love that fades to black
Once revealed, won’t be taken back
Light nothing can escape
The ignorance we once forgave
In the future,
if we don't decide to change
The things we cannot save
But it slows to shine upon your face
We owe everything
Everything
To this rainbow of suffering
Light is particle and wave
Refractions of this place
Reflections of our grace
It reveals what we hold dear
And it’s slow so I can hold you near
(Music ends)
(Applause)
There's one thing I know for certain.
That we clear the static
by being vulnerable
and by telling the truth.
And here we are doing just that.
Thank you.
(Applause)